these are their stories
so these are the group of people
involved
who's this little girl approach them
it's a little girl yeah
it's a time woman
she's like five one at Best essentially
what's going on if you're not really
clear because there's no sound is she
she lost her phone she convinced someone
stole it she thinks it's these guys so
she goes up to them and as that's
happening that's what's going on in
front of you
and so some other people get involved
they start pushing her away telling her
to get away
[Music]
the girl tries pulling the dude back
he's kind of cheesed
[Music]
if you're five foot one
and as a group of people and you think
they stole something from you
why you would think it's a good idea for
you to go out to them and start accusing
them even if you're right because
they're not allowed to hit women
trust me there's some guys who don't
subscribe to that they'll deck you so
hard just ask the other lady who's into
fitness and was walking her dog he asked
for the wallet she said no she got a
hammer to the eye almost lost her
eyesight he said sorry
he did apologize to good manners the
other day he's just like [__] you small
you're weak other than this whole like
you can't hit a woman thing there's
nothing protecting you from the savagery
of a lot of other people recognize that
because generally even if you [__] up
it's not going to be you that's going to
suffer those consequences it's gonna be
other people around you it's gonna be
your boyfriend it's gonna be your male
friend it's gonna be the people who try
to step in for a situation that you
created think you're Invincible well if
you're so Invincible why can't you stop
your homie from getting his ass beat
it's because you're not
to me
she says something she can't stop her
homie from getting his ass whooped if he
steps in can she
stop you're hitting him stop
nobody cares how many dudes do you see
get beat up over a girl she said you
smile before I even finish my sentence
how many times you've seen the Captain
Save A hope in a situation where the
girl was clearly in the wrong being an
idiot because that's the national sports
sports and bars there you go that's what
we see ketchup fish ketchup knee that's
a bottle yeah shirt behind the neck so
they're surrounding her right now now I
think some other people are coming in
figure shoes on the outside people are
trying to pull her away
then they're trying to pull the other
guys away
the ones who supposedly took the phone
she's still standing there talking to
them okay and this is how I know
a lot of y'all don't know about the
escalation the situation has calmed down
you just got lucky not getting your ass
beat walk away
you don't have the physical capabilities
to take them on hand on hand they
outnumber you Tony to one and you don't
even know if they got weapons this is
what I call stupidness
okay this is based in a lot of privilege
that's what I'm about to say
and I ain't talking about white black
whatever someone felt like nothing could
happen to them
because of a different privilege that
they had and they went in and they did
the thing
so now they're surrounding her they're
going all around her and they're they're
just looking for a reason to Snuff this
girl
seeing people are pulling away because
they can see the danger right no no this
is not good no no because she run you oh
you keep running your mouth now yeah
yeah yeah yeah they're circling around
get out of there right thankfully the
other dude's got some people to pull
them away you know especially teenagers
no cause him I'm gonna say teenagers act
a fool
okay okay did you see that he just
passed him something
did I just see that
[Music]
he dabbed him up
oh they leaving they're leaving they're
leaving they're leaving okay he's
looking for a problem he's back he's
he's not gonna he's oh he took off his
hat see this one you get away now
they're trying to hold it this man
pulling up his pants he's trying to
Haymaker this girl oh no they're being
somebody else
oh oh oh the one who tried to help her
well and they all came back
oh they're chasing him see and look at
the security guards who can't do [__]
look at the security guards look at them
they're trying to Snuff them the
security guys are trying to protect them
oh they got him now it's over he ran
right into them
oh now they snuffing him now where's the
girl where's the girl where's the girl
uh down there somewhere
where's the girl there she's there no
that's another girl that's a girl she
was with the other ones that's not her
she's way taller
she's about to beat him up too hold up
where'd the girl go let me see where the
girl went here she is
oh wait wait some other go beat her up
she did get snuffed oh wait no she's
right there someone hits her this black
girl's gonna hit her
[Music]
oh wow they all get
oh now you crying this right here
[Music]
now she's crying oh look she can say it
while her homie the one who came to her
rescue is getting stomped out but she
got her beating and now she left and
look at him he didn't stop they kicking
him and she left oh and they dragged him
into the bushes oh my God they're
beating this man and he and she left she
left
and this is how it always happens
and they still stomping on him he's on
the floor the security guards are right
there
and like like I told y'all young people
don't give a [__] there's a lot of young
people out there listen especially when
you're that when you're young a lot of
Reckless Behavior is going to happen and
you know what the craziest part is the
people who got beat are lucky
that none of these people had any
weapons on them I'm pretty sure I saw
one of them hand something off what's
that what's that
there's two options either that was her
phone or that was a weapon either way
this was a lose-lose situation so I
don't know for me in terms of
situational awareness you got to know
what you're going up against me
personally if I would have seen that
nothing I could do
there's no what you want me to do they
in a group like that I want my phone
back what do you want me to do maybe you
try to have a conversation I'm not mad
at that I'm not saying you can't talk to
folks
okay but you gotta be smart about things
especially man that girl was bugging she
got her ass beat
and so did the dude who tried to help
her I mean it's fair
everybody got beat you get a beating you
get a beating everybody gets a beating
but the girl who beat him it's a girl
who beat him up her beat her up the girl
yeah the girl yeah girl she was she was
probably running her mouth she was
probably writing her mouth and now you
got another guy to punch him and let's
look nobody listen A girl turned around
it's like yeah they can't touch you
because you're a woman I'm here and
someone's gonna say well they probably
did steal it why would they be so
aggressive if you've ever been accused
by somebody or something you didn't do
you get really upset
you get really upset yeah and it has
happened you guys don't remember that
story we told you about where this guy
was at a hotel with her his dad he's a
17 year old and this woman jumped on him
yeah and assaulted him yeah and he never
had the phone and she ended up finding
it later people get falsely accused all
the time for Tiff like this she was
found guilty she found guilty damn right
go to jail [__] who told you you could
put put your hands on on a young man who
told you that and do all that commotion
no no no no no he had my phone okay all
right wasn't it me upon Seto me up on
set yeah was it her yeah you know what
I'm saying so at the end of the day be
smarter
listen if you lose your phones get the
cops involved go ask for camera footage
maybe get a name but don't be out there
trying to be a superhero you're not
special I'm gonna go get my phone back
yeah and and you doing that got someone
else beating five nothing and this dude
is is this dude got snuffed you got
snuffed who knows who knows what
happened to him after being beaten on
the floor like that security was there
and they couldn't do [__] there was
three of them three of them so they
gonna do [__] so just be smart about
that kind of stuff you guys got to be
safe out there situational awareness you
know why but you got to be brave you a
[__] cause if it was me I would have
snuff them out
yeah
yeah and I'm gonna also say this having
a gun doesn't save this situation either
you know just because you have a gun
doesn't mean you go up to a group of
people antagonize them start a situation
and think you're gonna start shooting
listen Second Amendment wonderful thing
I support all of it I think gun rights
and ownership is a wonderful thing but
it also comes with a lot of
responsibilities you guys don't become
superheroes because you have a gun it
should be the last line of defense not
something you lead with all right it's
not some [__] insurance policy that
you take into every argument just so you
can be a hot head there's a lot of
people who own guns who think that
they're cowboys you're not
and those people end up often killing
folks and then going to jail themselves
right look at the folks who did the
Ahmad arbory thing
they're looking at what murder charges
murder charges okay so at the end of the
day be smart with these situations a
phone is never worth a life and I don't
know if any life got lost here I don't
know but it easily could have if any of
them were carrying weapons and they
wanted to jerk these people they would
have
just if you don't know what that means
all right so just be smart what would
you have done that's okay
I don't know I told you already
I don't know I'm telling you I'm here
and I'm giving you all these advices and
[__] like that because that's a sensible
thing to do but of course whenever
you're in the Heat of the Moment you
don't know what's going on
but you really have to think hard to
think and do the right thing in these
situations
and that's what martial arts taught me
you know you have to slow things down to
be able to do the right decision so I
don't know what I would have done
and what I might mean martial arts I'm
not talking about beating the ass I'm
talking about the whole situation you do
martial arts it's not just fighting and
beating a [__] up that's not
what it is it's the whole thing is
decision thinking right you have to take
decision you have to assess what's going
on and you have to say you have to be
able to assess what's the best solution
and sometime in martial arts the best
solution is to flee
Sometimes the best solution is not to
stay there and take the punches actually
when you do martial arts most of the
time what they're going to tell you to
do a good martial artist a good teacher
is going to be like your first first
thing if you can get the [__] out and
you don't have to be there
get out if you're stuck in a wall and
you have to defend yourself that's
another story but the first defense is
get the [__] out well they say the best
defense is a better offense but best
defenses get the [__] out that's in
sports where the stakes aren't the same
the best defense is get the [__] out
that's definitely it get the [__] out
sometimes it's the retreat yeah please
the best defense it doesn't make your
coward the best defense Specialists are
the ones who never get who never get
into fights it's like what are the best
boxers the ones who don't get hit
if I could use them if you know what I'm
saying yeah if I could use a metaphor
it's like yeah
you have policy
oh [__] it's really slippery
I'm gonna go beat that I'm gonna go
straight to that car I got entrance
that's a bit the same thought process
because you got your insurance which is
your Martial Arts I'm gonna go right in
there no even if you have an insurance
policy and everything is going to be a
right offer or you're gonna have your
your belonging back you still have to
slow down when it snows you know I mean
your insurance policy is really if [__]
goes down but if you're on the road and
it's sleeper slippery or dangerous or
your vision is reduced what do you do
you gonna no you slow down same logic
and it's not only dangerous for the
woman who made the approach on a
physical scale what if things got really
bad and she ended up let's say let's say
she's a Kung Fu Master right and she
starts popping [__] next left to right
okay Mulan I mean Hidden Dragon
crouching something okay she's killing
him
and they don't have her phone
now she just beat people
you see what I'm saying you know what
I'm saying so now she just made an
assault exactly right so just be mindful
that think about that uh and uh yeah
just be safe out there
[Music]
foreign